all right everybody here's the story
from the Daily Mail quote let me start
with two words made in America and that
was it and I just started busting out
laughing because uh you know look we
could talk about a lot of stuff we can
talk about Joe Biden destroying the
country and getting us involved in
potentially World War III but uh we get
we deserved we deserve to laugh and I
don't know if I okay so I don't have it
here do they got the video Let's Play
the video we started off with two words
made in America
[Applause]
he says it twice and then everybody
cheers for it
that's it happy Friday everybody I hope
you're having a good time this is um
you know are we laughing as everything
just spirals down into Oblivion and we
just you know we're just smiling as it
all Burns around us this is fine uh not
also not all burning around us it's
always been you know trying to make the
best out of a chaotic uh Universe
um but yeah I'm definitely laughing as I
should probably be trying to figure out
a new sort of economy that we could
transition to I love how the story from
the Daily Mail is highlighting the fact
that he's had two words he's like let me
start with two words but then says three
but then it gets like really serious
with like letters you know from the rep
from representatives from Congresswoman
Nancy mace and pictures of you know Rand
Paul and all that stuff and it's like
dude I'll bet you the White House
transcript is going to read he said
three words instead of two and they're
gonna feed a whitewash few words few
words there you go let me start with a
few words
Lydia pointed out he technically did
start with two made in so maybe
yeah that's a Kareem jean-pierre's gonna
say someone's gonna be like the
president said to start with two words
but then said three he started by saying
two words and then added a third okay
that's two two how's it going how's the
economy for you guys how's how's your
how's the country are you are you
excited for the leadership of this man
oh yeah absolutely he's definitely very
competent and I'm so happy he's in
charge as we are on the brink of
Armageddon as he says himself last night
he was literally talking about how we're
we're closer to Armageddon since the
first time since the Cuban Missile
Crisis he's also talking about how Putin
is deadly serious about using tactical
nukes in Ukraine and uh
yeah I don't know yeah look at that look
at this tweet this is a good one it's
the first it's it's uh one of these
gotcha tweets Joe Biden says you won't
have to worry about my tweets when I'm
president and then under it it says
President Joe Biden says the risk of
nuclear Armageddon is at the highest
level since the Cuban Missile Crisis my
response was yeah right I mean come on
no Mean Tweets yeah like there you go
but I just love that that juxtaposition
you don't got to worry about my tweets
and then the news bit the world is about
to end
I wonder if he's setting us up to be a
hero like he's like hey I I have heard
of world war three everybody we're like
yeah but you got us close to it too in
the first place hey but I did get you
away from it I mean she's like I saved
you from nuclear war like
like you almost started it but I didn't
save you from it he did come out with
the marijuana stuff was that yesterday
yeah yeah but apparently it's not
actually exonerating anybody the
apparently the marijuana thing is just
going to like your past convictions are
you raced yeah I saw that oh it's not
letting people out no it's not letting
people out they can't get out of jail
even for federal offenses
it seemed that it was a pardon I the
language pardon was in there for
thousands of I don't know if it's
current or past I think it's passed I I
so
I see a lot of these lefties being like
Joe Biden's a great president because he
just pardoned all these marijuana you
know convictions or whatever and I was
like oh that's cool like I'm I'm in
favor of that I think Trump should have
done the same thing and then and then my
response is like how many people were
released and everyone said none it was
just exonerating like their records and
they're trying to reschedule it because
that's the value yeah right because if
they take it off a schedule one then
they'll stop treating it like heroin and
stop throwing people in federal prison
for it isn't that crazy though that
basically the only reason pot became
legal is because everyone just decided
it was and ignored the law like they
were they were I I was talking about
this with Half Baked it's literally a
movie from the 2000s is it was it late
90s I don't know where a bunch of dudes
are just outright committing crimes and
it's relatable and funny
it's just weird like even in it the you
know when Dave Chappelle is at the lab
and the doctor rips the huge chunk off
and hands it to him just like it's a
tragedy what they did to marijuana in
the 1900s that what was it Harry J Ann
Slinger and uh William Randolph Hearst
got together Hurst owned all these trees
and he wanted to take people off of the
hemp paper industry and make you know
well paper industry wanted to make trees
so he he got Harry J and Slinger and I
think he was the guy his Congress Point
man to start printing up all this
propaganda like Reefer Madness make
people afraid they said that black it
made black people like blood bloodlusty
and stuff like crazy
nonsensical propaganda that wasn't true
and uh they made enough people afraid of
it that they were able to make it
federally illegal and then William
Randall first had the Monopoly on the
paper trade after that
it's stuck for a long time
I mean I think that's that's an
interesting story right he was uh he was
like a newspaper magnate or whatever is
that you pronounce that yeah you look at
the people who control the narratives
when they have the ability to manipulate
and control media and you see what ends
up happening because of it they can just
be like this thing goes against my
interest so have my newspapers tell
everybody to do as I say and they do
freaking nuts but he did it with
congress's help which is what really
makes it scandalous yeah but the thing
about Congress
you know the Republicans are a great
example Republicans are more concerned
about the opinion of the New York Times
and the opinion of their own
constituents and that's that's exactly
the power of the media so with the
internet the reason why we're seeing big
Tech freak out the way it is and this
whole Elon Musk thing is becomes such a
big deal is we've we've I I'm us I guess
you know many of us especially you guys
Minds we've taken away their ability to
just monopolize The Narrative and
they're losing their minds because of it
and they're losing power because of it
and they're you know it's like it's like
watching a dude sinking in quicksand
screaming and thrashing around and you
wanna you wanna feel bad you're like I
know that they're sinking and they're
like doomed but they're also just really
evil so you can only just sit back and
be like maybe they we shouldn't have
this apparatus anymore you know what I
mean yeah I'd still like to encourage
them to not thrash so much because
that's what's causing them to sink maybe
it's the thrashing that's evil not the
actual person it's yeah if they just you
know laid forward
and that you your legs come out and then
you can crawl away but they don't get it
they're just swinging violently
screaming and you know it's like when we
uh we had this raccoon problem and you
know we want to feel bad for this
raccoon but we're trying to kill our
chickens so when we walk up to the Trap
and we're like oh the poor little thing
is and we're like ah they're like get it
out of here and then wait to get rid of
it you know that's what it's like it's
if the media is failing it's dying and
these people are losing their jobs and
all that and then I'm just like yeah but
they're like nasty people who just fling
crap at your face you know you walk up
to them you feel bad like maybe you know
these journalists you know I see they're
they're panicking maybe they need work
and then they just fling feces right at
you and you're like okay dude okay go
away you don't deserve to have a job I
guess you would think Twitter would be
changing amid seeing the reaction to the
Elon takeover like but they still
they're thrashing they they continue to
ban even despite
this lawsuit that's happening and the
like so what is your current take on the
the situation like because Twitter wants
Elon Twitter wants the the court
um trial to happen still yeah yeah
because because Elon was asking for more
time and they said making sure the trial
still happens until this finalizes like
prevents Mischief or something I guess
it's their poop tweets they're concerned
about it I don't want any more poop
emoji from you know what man like ah
just bill was late to the show so
normally what we do is we get a
thumbnail where the guest is sitting
across from me and then I press record
and then I screenshot it but Bill wasn't
here so I was just like empty chair it
is and I just want to say like that's
that right there is the big difference
between the establishment and the
traditional media machine and what we
represent we can just screw around like
that and be silly about it and have fun
and just it is what it is and I was like
if this was like a major Network they'd
be panicking they'd be like Paul
archival we got to get something we
can't be we have to wear our suits and
ties yeah you can't have fake bazunkas
on National Television no could you
imagine a guest going on Tucker Carlson
with gigantic fake boobies like Luke did
yeah I mean Fox would probably have you
know
did you see that Danny project got got a
pair oh he did yeah good that from that
high school teacher thing or whatever
yeah he got he got like yeah he was
doing videos what's he doing I didn't I
I just saw a photo of it when they
arrived at his house I didn't see the
video yet what do you think of the Elon
buying Twitter I mean bring it on it's
better than status quo you know we saw
did you guys see his text with Dorsey
some of them yeah so it's like they both
are admit you know Dorsey what's
infuriating is that he knows open source
decentralization encryption Bitcoin he
knows that this is all where it needs to
go but he had decades to make that
happen with Twitter and couldn't do it
he even said in the text I don't have
power I have three percent of the
company I can't do anything but he was
telling Elon this is where you need to
take it he was saying there's there
needs to be no company actually because
the company becomes an attack Vector
right so
IT company lists decentralized Protocols
are what we need that's what's beautiful
about Bitcoin because Satoshi is totally
Anonymous no there's no one to go after
why is it why isn't why didn't Dorsey do
anything I I know he had that that one
operation what was that called this guy
blue sky right yeah it still exists it's
you know they're they're doing research
and stuff but I don't you know and then
when the transition happened and uh the
new CEO is coming in parag he Dorsey to
this blog post where he was like I feel
in my gut that this is really the right
decision for the company you know we're
gonna you know things are gonna get
better and then it's just like nothing
changes there's no you know in fact his
Prague statements about Free Speech are
the opposite thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there